let's go back to the religious analogy
like i mean you never met jesus why go
to church on sunday you know it's
there's there's an aspect of faith to
all of these things and including money
in general are you comparing satoshi
nakamoto to jesus i i think there's a
lot of really applicable analogies there
really absolutely 100
well i mean it's it's it's somebody
people people disagree whether or not
like who he is whether it's one person
or many
uh you know what was he in fact there's
there's all kinds of people on the
internet what was it an ai from the
future has he come back you know like he
was jewish though for sure but satoshi
or jesus
so jesus is from the tribe of judah and
yes very much to help adam understand
better you could say satoshi is more
like biden you never know where he is
you know just to help you you know he's
making peace
in my opinion satoshi nakamoto is an
australian man
who is a i'm i'm a firm believer that
that craig wright is the primary
architect of bitcoin i believe he wrote
the white paper
and you just pissed a lot of people oh i
know this is the single most right this
is the most unpopular thing in fact i
guarantee you're lighting up right now
with ah this guy's a scammer kick them
out your reputation's done
craig wright um so craig wright is right
now in in miami yeah there's a lawsuit
going on right now florida the largest
private lawsuit of all time there's
about 160 billion dollars being asked
they're saying that they're saying that
it's the trial of the century it was oj
now it's satoshi do you know who started
calling it the trial of the century
jazlyn maxwell's lawyers that's yours
yes
very hard on that do not look here look
over there please when you say miami
there's art basel going on this week
it's a big deal there's a lot of nft
crypto stuff going on at the art basel
art obviously then there's the um
defy conference going on near the
airport is that why
craig writes in town is that why no no
craig wright is in town at federal court
he is likely at the milky d ferguson
federal court building right now the
jury is actually deliberating the case
is over and the jury is currently
deliberating we're actually expecting a
verdict today but it's a civil it's a
civil suit not a criminal it is a civil
suit between the estate of dave clyman
which which says that dave was 50 of of
the satoshi nakamoto team and then craig
wright says absolutely he was not a
business partner in any regard he was my
dear friend he did help me edit the
white paper but he always helped me out
at white papers he was essentially a
contractor who was also a friend but
bitcoin was my idea i'm the architect of
it he helped me with some of the
trimmings and and i'm happy to deal with
that but but he does not get fifty
percent of of my my invention you
interviewed chris i did did you not i
did and by the way yeah we had a great
time together so it's a phenomenal
conversation i just i enjoy talking to
him but i gotta tell you afterwards
after interviewing craig wright there's
only been about well i can't say that
he's probably in the top ten interviews
that i got the most dms emails twice
people pissed off
about having craig right on so go back
into why you think it is craig rock
because there's a lot of different names
that you hear about why why him sure so
this really should be prefaced with the
bitcoin civil war this is this is why
this is not this is not just a cultural
disagreement thing this is this is
israel versus palestine kind of stuff
sunni shia
this is exactly never going to agree on
anything exactly so the the reason that
i think it's craig wright first of all
is that every other potential candidate
makes absolutely zero sense so people
bring up like nick zabo or they bring up
uh even hal finney how finney what's up
with that how finney's a very cool guy
he's very talented software engineer he
fundamentally disagreed with satoshi in
public i mean you can read their
conversations hal finney didn't
understand bitcoin he was a software
engineer and very talented and satoshi
gave him software work to do none of
this is contentious but hal never
understood bitcoin he argued with
satoshi about how it should be
engineered so satoshi does exist satoshi
absolutely exists he exists yes also dan
pena is full of [ __ ] first time ever
first time ever he does dan pena dan
paid yeah
first time he's been right about
literally everything i've always i like
dan pena but but i i think he's going to
want to vote here
so so the other guys like they look at
bitcoin and they say ah it's got
security problems everybody would need
to run a node it can't scale and satoshi
always argued with these guys no no it
can scale no you do not need to run a
node only people that are trying to mine
coins need to run a node so there's this
big disagreement on all these
definitions in bitcoin so we can't even
get past the basic presuppositions of
what is bitcoin how is bitcoin yeah all
of that this this sounds like an iron
sword and this is this is been from
social media day one so the very first
response when satoshi put the white
paper out and said hi i'm satoshi i've
solved the double spend problem here's
the bitcoin white paper the first guy
came out to say well here's why it
doesn't work and they have this this
rant that is very typical even in social
media today well it can't scale because
everyone would need to run a node and
then it would have this problem and then
you can't propagate blocks and blah blah
blah and satoshi basically gave the big
blocker version this is the side of
bitcoin that i fall on of saying no
absolutely not bitcoin could do
visa level transactions today with
existing hardware
and he explained the basics on how but
he didn't go really deeply into it he
said but nonetheless the network hasn't
even launched yet but don't worry nodes
can consolidate into commercial
operations where everyone connects into
what is essentially what we know today
as a mining pool
and describes out
all the ways that it can scale and how
it should work and people
started to fight immediately so the very
first conversation was actually the
opening shots of the bitcoin civil war
and we haven't gotten past it
and then satoshi very suddenly
disappeared in late 2010 so the white
paper came out in 2008 late 2008 and
then he was gone by 2010 largely forced
out basically sick of bickering is the
way that i see it because it was
everybody saying oh satoshi you don't
get it and he's just saying like don't
tell me what i don't get about the thing
that i architected
and then at some point he just said you
know what i have so many other things to
do i'm going to pass the keys to
gavin andreessen he's the new lead
developer you guys are
okay and then he specifically said stop
referring to me as a shadowy figure and
stop treating bitcoin like crime money
that kind of thing like that's not what
he was interested in
and so then satoshi was gone and then
immediately his his repo was moved from
sourceforge and put onto github and a
bunch of new people were put in charge
and then all his stuff was burned down
the history of satoshi was whitewashed
and then it turned into hey here's this
big uh investment opportunity and by the
way we're we're creating this new voting
process with soft forks and and bitcoin
improvement uh proposal systems we're
gonna have uh this this group of
maintainers and so it turned from
governance by proof of work which is in
my opinion the most important thing
that's been invented in the last
probably 50 years
and then it turned into what is
essentially a social democracy which is
everything wrong with money today is the
fact that there are gatekeepers and
people can vote on it and some of the
votes happen behind closed doors and
then people are given this illusion of
voting with their quote unquote nodes
but they're not actually voting like
what they've been given to vote on is
already the the milk toast that has been
approved by the various levels
let's step back a little bit because i
want to keep this simple for the
audience to understand it so uh uh
simplify story craig wright says he's
the only person that's come out and said
he's satoshi nakamoto right i don't
think he's not there are other people
that have claimed they are else has
that's a credible name who else has
because nobody credible everyone else is
following me give me the biggest name
that came out that said that phil wilson
is probably the most interesting guy
phil wilson for the record also says
well yeah it was me and craig and dave
so even phil who i think is kind of a
sketchy character he's another
australian fellow
and and he tells the story it was me
craig wright and dave clyman
the interesting thing is that phil
wilson worked at some of the same
companies as contractors and stuff as
craig so one of the big reasons why i
really think that it's craig is a craig
has a background in statistics finance
economics theology he's he's he's got
i don't even know half a dozen phds he's
got another 20 this master's degree
okay yeah i remember that so but craig
goes on bbc and he's going to put in the
keys and show the fact that he owns this
and then all of a sudden he's like oh
[ __ ] you know it's not working right and
it was a bit of a
you know controversial issue because if
you really say you are satoshi nakamoto
and you go on bbc and you kind of you
know flip-flop not able to show it he
lost a lot of credibility there's a
indeed and and this is why even to this
day he's he's among the most contentious
people in in the space they look at it
and say
if you couldn't prove it then you can't
prove it ever you're definitely not
satoshi nakamoto i think that's unfair
but the reason that i think it's unfair
is is specifically because i mean
there's a million reasons why that that
could be and i think that if he was a
scammer if this was all false he would
have disappeared at that point like who
wouldn't right if it's like okay the jig
is up i'm out let me give the question
back to you okay
uh uh uh everybody in this room just a
question for everybody in this room okay
you ready
uh how many guys have
forgotten your chase or bank of america
or wells fargo password yeah absolutely
have you yeah okay have you have you
ever have you ever yes you have you have
you have as well you have as well okay
uh would we put a guy named craig wright
with 10 phds that's one of the smartest
guys if he really created uh a
bitcoin you'd have to put him as one of
the smartest guys out there right sure
okay if he's one of the smartest guys
out there that produced a revolutionary
product by the way i want to believe it
sam i i enjoy talking to him i can't
wait to have him back on the podcast and
have the conversation with them if that
is the case the question that people
bring up is how does that guy forget it
because
the amount of money that he has is how
much is the money that he has 54 billion
or something no it's bigger than that
252 billion dollars yeah that was just
he would be the second richest man in
the world maybe the richest man today
because uh tesla took a hit
so so if you're if that is like but
that's why some people think that he
forgot the
the key as well so that they can
actually see go in and see exactly how
much he had how many hundreds of
thousands of coins he had in pre-mining
i mean if he was there it wasn't
pre-mined it was it was public it was it
was said three months before like hey
mining starts
sometime in the future let's get set up
like that that was the point of coming
with his partners pat i mean like like
the guy calvin air is the interesting
guy to me man like i mean who who
financed all this and if you financed
all this do you own bitcoin like do you
have an ownership state if you financed
everything are you the owner of bitcoin
have you financed everything and if you
know anything about calvin air people
that don't know calvin air go follow his
twitter he's a very
interesting character he's an
interesting character he's a and he's a
serious disrupter he he's the guy that
brought internet to half of canada uh he
took the money that he made from that
and and created a software company that
disrupted the gambling industry then he
basically took over the online gambling
industry with bowdog and became the
number one online gambling mogul period
he also invented uh a number of things
that ended up competing with paypal and
things like that back in the day which
is why he got into the bitcoin pretty
incredible stuff also has a predilection
for females that even dan bilzerian's
like i don't know bro that's a little
young
you know
some of the stuff has come up in the
past and the people that have brought it
up have ended up having to uh
pay restitution and things to calvin so
it's
there are accusations and nothing's been
nothing's ever been proven charges have
never come out or any of that and he
happily shares the pictures across
twitter and very much understands the
legality issues that that would arise
should these things be uh
you know illegal so i i
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]